time AI is going to change the way we
teach learn and help solve challenges
like disease and climate change and
giving give me the time to focus on the
things that matter most to you
personally
and but in seizing this moment we need
to manage the risks to our society to
our economy and our national security
my Administration is committed it's
committed to safeguarding America's
rights and safety
from protecting privacy to addressing
bias and disinformation to making sure
AI systems are safe before they are
released last October we proposed an AI
Bill of Rights to ensure that important
protections were built into the AI
systems from a very start
earlier this year I signed an executive
order to direct my cabinet to root out
bias in the design and use of AI and in
may we announced a new strategy for
funding response for responsible AI
development so Americans can lead the
way and drive breakthroughs in this
critical area from cyber security to
Public Health to our Agriculture and
education and quite frankly so much more
social media has already shown us the
harm and power that powerful not
powerful technology can do without the
right safeguards in place
that's why I said at the State of the
Union that Congress needs to pass
bipartisan privacy legislation to impose
strict limits on personal data
collection banned targeting advertising
to our children and require companies to
put health and safety first next month
the vice president will be will convene
a civil rights leaders of America
consumer protection groups and Civil
Society to continue that our
Administration is ongoing engagement on
AI but today I'd like to hear more from
this group because I have a lot to learn
and we also have a lot to discuss so I'd
like to ask the press to lead the room
thank you for coming in
thank you
I'm very proud of my son
foreign